I'M BROOKE BALDWIN.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS TRAFFIC
STOP THAT TURNED UGLY.
RYAN BROWN AND HIS BROTHER
BENJAMIN WERE PULLED OVER BY
POLICE IN MARCH.
HE HIT RECORD ON HIS CELL PHONE.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED NEXT.
>> WHAT'S THE REASON WHY PULLED
US OVER, OFFICER?
I'M RECORDING THIS.
A POLICE OFFICER HAS PULLED US
OVER FOR NO REASON.
I GOT THIS ON CAMERA.
>> DO YOU HAVE YOUR I.D.?
>> I HAVE MY CAMERA -- I HAVE MY
I.D., AND I'M RECORDING THIS TO
LET YOU KNOW.
>> I'D LIKE YOU TO PASS ME YOUR
I.D., PLEASE.
KEEP YOUR HANDS WHERE I CAN SEE
THEM.
>> ARE UNDER ARREST?
YOU FAILED TO IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
I DON'T KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
>> OFFICER, YOU KNOW I'M A
POLICE OFFICER WITH THE CITY OF
CLOUDY SPRINGS --
>> YOU FAILED TO IDENTIFY
YOURSELF.
>> I JUST NEED YOUR I.D. NOW.
>> YOU FAILED TO OUTSIDE
YOURSELF.
MY HANDS ARE VISIBLE.
I HAVE THE RECORDER RECORDING.
MY BROTHER IS BEING PUT IN
HANDCUFFS.
WE'RE PULLED OVER FOR NO REASON.
HE STILL HAS NOT IDENTIFIED WHY
HE'S PULLED US OVER.
NOW I'M BEING PERCEIVED AS A
THREAT BECAUSE WE'RE BEING
PULLED OVER FOR ABSOLUTELY NO
REASON.
AM I BEING PLACED UNDER ARREST?
>> YOU'RE NOT UNDER ARREST.
>> YOU'RE NOT COOPERATING --
>> I'M ASKING FOR A REASON WHY
WE'RE BEING PULLED OVER.
AND YOU HAVE STILL FAILED TO
IDENTIFY WHY YOU'VE PULLED US
OVER.
>> I'M NOT PULLING YOU --
>> YOU'RE NOT --
>> COME ON UP.
WHY ARE YOU PULLING ME OUT OF MY
CAR?
TAKE YOUR HANDS OFF ME.
I HAVE NOT DID NOTHING.
I HAVE NO WEAPONS.
YOU HAVE NO REASON TO PULL ME
OUT OF THE CAR.
>> THIS IS ASSAULT --
>> TURN AROUND.
TURN AROUND.
>> YOU SEE THIS?
YOU SEE THIS?
EXCESSIVE FORCE.
>> AND WITH HIS FACE DOWN IN THE
GRASS, YOU SAW THE VIDEO END.
THE BROTHERS WERE PLACED IN
PLACE CARS AND SERVED FOR
RESISTING AND INTERFERING WITH A
PUBLIC OFFICIAL.
THEY WERE CHARGED WITH MINOR
OFFENSES.
THE MAN THERE, RYAN BROWN, NOW
JOINS ME.
HE IS JOINED BY HIS ATTORNEY,
DANIEL WRECHT, FORMER CHAIRMAN
OF THE ACLU IN COLORADO.
WITH ME, STEVE ROGERS, AN EXPERT
IN COMMUNITY POLICING AND
RETIRED LIEUTENANT OF NUTLEY,
NEW JERSEY, POLICE.
WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU.
I ALL HAVE THE RESPONSE FROM
COLORADO SPRINGS' POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
SO WE'LL GET TO THAT.
FIRST, RYAN, WE SAW SOME OF
OBVIOUSLY WHAT HAPPENED BECAUSE
OF THE CELL PHONE.
WHAT HAPPENED BETWEEN WHEN
POLICE PULLED YOU OVER TO WHEN
WE SEE YOUR BROTHER GETTING
HANDCUFFED OUT OF THE DRIVER'S
SIDE OF THE CAR?
>> YES.
FIRST OF ALL, I WANTED TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> SURE.
>> THE OFFICER, WHEN HE PULLED
US OVER, HE APPROACHED THE
VEHICLE.
HE ASKED MY BROTHER, ASKED FOR
HIS LICENSE.
THAT WAS THE FIRST THING HE
ASKED FOR.
MY BROTHER SPEXPLAINED I DON'T
HAVE MY LICENSE ON ME RIGHT --
WE LIVE RIGHT HERE.
WE'RE RIGHT DOWN THE STREET.
WE LIVE A COUPLE HOUSES DOWN.
HE EXPLAINED THAT TO THE
OFFICER.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM GIVING MY
LICENSE.
FROM THEN, THE OFFICER TOLD MY
BROTHER TO GET OUT OF THE
VEHICLE AND COME TO HIS PATROL
CAR TO IDENTIFY HIM.
AT THAT POINT, I TOLD THE
OFFICER, YOU KNOW, UNLESS MY
BROTHER'S UNDER ARREST, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY HE HAS TO GET OUT
OF THE VEHICLE.
APPARENTLY I GUESS THE OFFICER
DIDN'T LIKE MY RESPOND TO THAT.
HE DIDN'T LIKE THAT.
HE OPENED THE DOOR, HE PULLED
OUT HIS TASER, HE ARMED HIS
TASER, HE PULLED MY BROTHER FROM
THE VEHICLE, AND THAT'S WHEN I
TOLD MY BROTHER, YOU KNOW, GET
OUT.
COMPLY WITH HIS ORDERS.
FROM THAT POINT, I GRABBED MY
CAMERA AND STARTED RECORDING.
>> WERE THE TWO OF YOU ARRESTED?
WHAT HAPPENED AFTER THE VIDEO
WENT DEAD?
>> I WAS PLACED IN HANDCUFFS,
AND -- AND THROWN IN THE BACK OF
THE COP CAR UNTIL -- IT SEEMED
LAKE FOREVER.
ABOUT 30, 40 MINUTES.
>> THEN THEY LET YOU IF?
>> THEN THEY LET GO.
THEY SERVED ME AND RELEASED ME.
>> OKAY.
>> INITIALLY, THEY WERE --
SORRY, THEY TOLD ME I WAS BEING
PLACED UNDER ARREST.
>> I WANT TO WALK THROUGH THIS
STEP BY STEP BY STEP.
AND I HAVE A POLICE DETECTIVE
NEXT TO ME.
I HAVE QUESTIONS BEFORE I WANT
YOU TO CONTINUE.
SO STEVE, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
POLICE REPORT, IT INDICATED THAT
THE TRAFFIC STOP WAS DRIVING
SLOWLY IN A HIGH CRIME AREA.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT FIRST?
>> YOU KNOW HOW YOU AND I HAVE
TALKED ABOUT HOW EVERYTHING
BOILS DOWN TO TRAINING.
HAD THE OFFICERS HAD REASONABLE
SUSPICION -- THAT'S A KEY WORD
-- THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS WERE
ARMED AND DANGEROUS, WHAT THEY
DID WAS APPROPRIATE TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES.
BUT THAT WAS NOT THE CASE.
WHEN THEY STOPPED THIS
INDIVIDUAL, THEY SHOULD HAVE
TOLD HIM WHY THEY STOPPED HIM.
EVERYTHING WENT DOWNHILL.
>> LET ME JUMP IN, TO BE CRYSTAL
CLEAR, YOU HEAR YOUR VOICE
ASKING WHY ARE YOU PULLING ME
OVER, WHY -- IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES.
DID THEY EVER EXPLAIN WHY THEY
WERE PULLING YOU OVER AND ANSWER
THE OTHER QUESTIONS YOU WERE
ASKING?
>> HE HAD --
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> HE HAD THE RIGHT TO KNOW WHY
HE WAS PULLED OVER.
AFTER YOU PULL SOMEONE OVER, IF
THEY FAIL TO COMPLY, THEY'RE
OBJECT DISTRACTING THE
ADMINISTRATION.
JUST.
HE -- ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE.
HE DOES ASK, I SAW THE VIDEO.
HE ASKED DOZENS OF TIMES, WHY AM
I BEING PULLED OVER.
WHAT PUZZLED ME ALSO, HE WAS
ASKED IF HIGH WAS BEING PLACED
UNDER ARREST.
THEY CLEARLY SAID NO, THEN HE
WAS DRAGGED TO THE GROUND AND
HANDCUFFED.
IT'S PUZZLING HOW IT OCCURRED.
I THINK THERE'S A LACK OF
TRAINING, AND THAT HAS TO BE
ADDRESSED.
>> LET ME GET BACK TO THE
TRAINING, BUT TO BE FAIR TO THE
COLORADO SPRINGS POLICE
DEPARTMENT, HERE WHAT I HAVE.
JUST A LINE -- "POLICE
DEPARTMENT WAS TOLD THEY CANNOT
COMMENT ON THE CASE BECAUSE IT'S
AN ACTIVE INVESTIGATION.
"SO THERE'S THAT.
MY OTHER QUESTION, RYAN, YOUR
BROTHER WAS GETTING HANDCUFFED,
YOU KNOW, YOU OBVIOUSLY PULL
YOUR CELL PHONE OUT.
DID THE OFFICERS EXPLAIN TO YOU
WHY YOUR BROTHER WAS BEING
HANDCUFFED?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> GO AHEAD, GO AHEAD.
>> I'M SORRY.
THEY PULLED HIM FROM THE VE
VEHICLE, PLACED HIM IN HANDCUFFS
FOR NO APPARENT REASON.
AT LEAST WE WERE GIVEN NONE.
>> LET'S BE CLEAR, WHY WAS HE
PUT IN HANDCUFFS?
BECAUSE HE WAS A YOUNG BLACK
MAN.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
AND WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO HIS
BROTHER CAUGHT THIS ON VIDEO.
AND IN THE BEGINNING OF THE
VIDEO, YOU'LL SEE OUTSIDE OF THE
PASSENGER SIDE WINDOW AND THE
PASSENGER, MY CLIENT, NEXT TO ME
DID NOTHING WRONG.
A GUN HAS ALREADY BEEN PULLED ON
HIM.
WHEN HE STARTS THE VIDEO,
THERE'S A GUN ON HIS HEAD FROM
THAT SECOND FORWARD.
AND HE HAD DONE NOTHING WRONG.
>> I GOT TO TAKE IT.
>> JUMP IN.
>> WHETHER PEOPLE THROW THE RACE
CARD INTO -- WHEN PEOPLE THROW
THE RACE CARD INTO EVERY
INCIDENT, IT DOES BOIL MY BLOOD.
THESE POLICE OFFICERS, THEY HAVE
SOME EXPLAINING TO DO.
TO SAY IT WAS BECAUSE OF RACE IS
UNFAIR.
THE POLICE OFFICERS -- LOOK, WE
HAD AN OFFICER DIE IN THE CITY
OF NEW YORK LAST WEEK.
DO YOU KNOW WHY?
HE ASKED A QUESTION, WHAT'S IN
YOUR WAISTBAND, AND THAT GUY
KILLED HIM.
THESE POLICE OFFICERS HAVE TO
LOOK OUT FOR THEIR LIVES.
I'M NOT SAYING WHAT THEY DID
PROCEDURALLY OF RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DISCUSSING.
WHAT THEY DID PROCEDURALLY W
WRONG.
NOT RACE, FOR GOODNESS SAKES.
>> RYAN, DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
WERE TARGETED?
>> I HONESTLY DO.
I FEEL THEY WAS WHEN THE OFFICER
PULLED US OVER AND NOTICE ISSED
HE PULLED OVER A -- NOTICED HE
PULLED OVER A COUPLE OF BROTHERS
IT ESCALATED.
TO HAVE US PULLED OUT OF THE
VEHICLE FOR NO APPARENT REASON,
TO HAVE US THROWN TO THE GROUND
AND HAVE MY FACE SHOVED INTO THE
SNOW FOR ASKING A QUESTION, I
FEEL THAT'S EXCESSIVE.
I'M